The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So I guess we ought to start.
We seem to be a bit depleted.
Anyway, so today last time we
spoke about 4f imaging systems
and a bit about
spatial filtering.
And I guess we're going to do
quite a lot more on that today,
really.
So I mean this is really the
most basic part of Fourier
optics, really, I think so you
need to get lots of practice
seeing how it all works until
it comes second nature really.
So this is what
we said last time.
We went through
this slide last time
showing the significance
of the point spread
function of a low pass filter.
The idea is that if you
put in a point object--
i.e.
You put in an opaque
screen with a small hole
in, illuminate that with
light, this is going
to then give a spherical wave.
And then this lens is going to
collimate that spherical wave
to make a plane wave.
And in this back focal
plane of that lens,
you will get a nice
smooth variation here--
no variation, uniform
intensity, uniform amplitude,
which is basically
the Fourier transform
of this delta function.
Fourier transform of a delta
function is a constant,
isn't it?
And then this light then
goes through a pupil mask.
The plane wave after the mask
then gets to this second lens.
And the plane wave
is then focused down
and produces a focused spot
at some image plane, right?
So that's how it all works.
And so now what do
you actually see here?
What's the image of a
single point object?
What you see is the Fourier
transform of this pupil mask.
Because again, this is also
producing a Fourier transform.
Right, so the point
spread function--
what's called the amplitude
point spread function
is just the Fourier
transform of this pupil mask.
And we sometimes talk about
an intensity point spread
function, which is actually the
model of the square of that,
the intensity in that
image of a point object.
OK, so and this is
reminding you where
you might have come across
this sort of concept before.
This is like-- we spoke
in the last lecture about
if in electronics,
you might think
of an electronic system like
an amplifier or something
as a sort of black box.
You put in a signal, and
you get out a signal.
And you can characterize
that black box
by what's called the
impulse response, which
is the response that it would
give to a sharp spike going in.
All right, so ideally
you'd expect--
you'd want a sharp spike
to come out as well.
But in practice,
you don't get that.
You get some sort
of broader function
because of the imperfections
of the transfer system.
OK, so this is our
point spread function.
And it's denoted-- little
h of x dash, y dash.
This the x dash y dash plane.
And I guess this
terminology little h
seems to be pretty universal.
Goodman, I think, uses
that in other places.
All right, so this is
just now describing again
how you how you
calculate this 4 pi--
this 4f system.
We notice everywhere that
the input transparency
of a delta function
gives one here.
You multiply by the
pupil mask, and then you
do another Fourier
transform to find the image.
All right, so that's--
I ought to say something bit
more about the scaling of this.
Yeah, so you've got
of course, this.
The output point spread function
is a function of x dashed.
But, of course, when you do a
Fourier transform of something,
it's going to be a function
of frequency, not of distance,
isn't it?
So really this h
here, h of x dashed,
we get by doing the
Fourier transform of this,
and then transforming
the coordinates-- scaling
the coordinates in order to get
it into the coordinates x dash.
OK, so and then
last time, we also--
I'll go through this
very quickly, what
we said last time, if you've
got a low pass filter in 1D,
like a slip pupil, then the
pupil mask is a rect function.
And so if we're trying to
calculate the image of a point
object again, the field when
it gets to this pupil plane
is just a constant.
And so after it's gone
through the aperture,
it will have this sort
of amplitude variation.
And then so this is
what this is showing.
On the positive side is what's
on the negative side, which
is just 1 times
this, which is this.
And then if you then
Fourier transform that,
you find that the
point spread function
is going to be the
Fourier transform of this,
which is just the sync.
And then the point
spread function
is the Fourier
transform of this.
And then this is doing the
scaling of the coordinates
and getting it into
the right hand side.
I'm not going to
go through that.
We went through it last time,
but hopefully we're going to--
yeah, here we are.
And there's the sync.
Right, so this is that
the amplitude point
spread function or just normally
called point spread function.
Note that it goes negative.
This is 0 here.
So note that it goes
negative, right.
So you've got to convolve
that with your objects
to find the image of some
arbitrary objects, which we'll
carry on to talk
about in a minute.
This was just another
example of a phase filter
and the Fourier
transform of that.
But I don't think there's
point going through that again.
We'll just carry on now
where we've got up too,
which was to do with shift
invariance of the 4f system.
Now what we find--
what we've looked at is if we've
got a point object that we get
from this hole in
the screen, we get
an image which is this
amplitude point spread function.
The amplitude here would
be this Fourier transform
of this pupil mask.
Then, yeah I'd just mention,
there is this constant.
This is the point
spread function.
It's the Fourier transform
of this pupil mass.
But there's this constant
out at the front.
And this constant out at the
front is written like this.
And you can see that it's
made up of two parts.
First of all, this phase part--
this just comes about
because of the distance
the wave is traveled
through the optical system.
Right, so if it starts
off with zero phase here,
it's going to come up with
some particular finite phase
when it travels all this
distance through the system.
And then the other
bet is this F2
over F1, which is
a scaling factor,
the ratio of the focal lengths.
And basically you need that to
satisfy conservation of energy.
All right, so you can imagine
that as the point spread
function gets broader, then
it has to also get lower
because it has to contain
the right amount of energy
equal to the energy
going into the system.
So when you work
out the intensity
of this image of a
point, this would
be F2 over F1 squared, which
is the ratio of the heights--
the maximum intensities
of the center
of that image of a point.
Right, now so what we'll be
carrying on to look at now
is what happens if we
displace our point object.
We move this delta
function sideways.
And then let's
look, first of all,
at just the physical
situation of what's happening.
This produces a spherical wave.
And then when it goes
through the lens,
you can see that it's going
to produce again-- it's
going to be collimated
into a plane wave.
But now this plane wave is not
actually moving horizontally
but is moving at an angle.
And this comes about because
when you Fourier transform
this, you will get some
exponential phase factor, which
actually represents a wave
which is moving at an angle.
And then when this
inclined plane wave
goes through the
pupil mask, of course,
its angle doesn't
change anymore.
So it's still moving
at the same angle here.
And then again, it's collimated
and produces an image.
And the image-- what we find--
is the same as it was before.
The amplitude is exactly
the same as it was before.
But it's shifted.
So this is what we found before
when we looked at the image.
You got this-- you remember--
this inverted magnified image.
The inversion means that it's
the opposite side of the axis.
The scaling is this F2 over F1,
which comes about from the fact
that the focal
lengths are not equal.
But the important
thing to notice
is that apart from this shift,
this function is the same
as the function was before.
So what that means
is that this is
what's called shift invariance.
It means that the
image of a point
is independent of
where the point is.
Right, so that's a very
important property, which
simplifies things tremendously.
Yeah, and here's
a note just to say
that that is the lateral
magnification of this system
as we described before.
OK, so now this is just
showing this diagram again.
These are not meant
as sort of rays.
These are just sort of showing
regions where the light is
as it goes through.
But we've got this
amplitude here,
which is Fourier
transformed by a lens
and then goes through a mask,
Fourier transformed again
[AUDIO OUT] field.
So what this slide
is trying to show
is the significance of
the point spread function.
At some arbitrary objects--
we can think of an
arbitrary object g of t,
an arbitrary transparency.
You can you can think of--
sorry.
You're illuminating
that with some field.
So what actually you get
after the transparency
is the products of those two.
So is the g in that I
really meant to talk about.
The g in you can think
of as being made up
of lots of delta functions.
Any arbitrary function,
you can divide it up
into lots of delta
functions where
the strength of each of them
corresponds to the strength
of that function at that point.
Right, so this is what
this expression here
is writing down.
So the g in is written as--
you can write it as an
integral over delta functions
with the strength
given by the function.
But each of those
delta functions
is going to propagate
through this system
and produce a point
spread function exactly
like we described before.
And then the image
of the total object
is going to be the sum
of the images of all
these delta functions.
So all of these delta functions
produce point spread functions.
So you integrate over those
point spread functions
with the relative strengths
that you need from here
and you'll get the final image.
And yeah, you can
see that this is
a bit like Huygens principle,
that you are breaking up
this wavefront into lots
of components that are all
represented as delta functions.
OK, so therefore what we get out
is going to be this integral.
Each of these delta
functions is going
to produce an image given by
this point spread function.
The point spread function
is shifted a distance
which depends on the
original distance
but is scaled according
to this factor we just
mentioned earlier.
And the strength
of that component
is given by this value g in at
this point as we said there.
So our final expression says
that the output amplitude,
but amplitude convolved with
the point spread function.
Right, so this
expression-- you can see--
is exactly the same as
an ordinary convolution
expression, except [AUDIO OUT]
But you can see it's
like [AUDIO OUT]
OK, yeah so because
of this scaling,
we can-- and also the
inversion as well,
we sometimes express
things in terms
of a reduced optical
output coordinates.
So we think of the
output coordinate
as being [? measured ?]
[AUDIO OUT] to get rid
of the sine and also
scaled it to get rid
of the scaling factor.
And if we do it in terms of
these reduced quantities,
then you can write this as
are just a normal convolution
expression.
So all we've done
really is scaled
the output coordinates
in order to make it
so that you can use the
normal convolution expression.
And then we think
back to our case
I was mentioning before of
the electronic black box.
So an electronic black
box, you can either
characterize in terms
of an impulse function
or in terms of a
transfer function.
So an impulse
function-- you look
at a delta function in time
and look at what comes out.
In terms of a transfer function,
you put in a pure frequency
and you look at
the output that you
get from that pure frequency.
Right, so we can do exactly
the same for the optical case,
instead of thinking in terms of
a point spread function, which
is the same as this
impulse response,
we can think in terms
of a transfer function.
And now one thing
to be very clear
here is of course,
this whole thing,
we're talking about
coherent systems.
So we're working with
amplitudes all the time.
And so it's the
amplitudes that are
going to be affected
by the optical system.
And that's why we have
to think of what's called
an amplitude transfer function.
All right, and we've written
that as ATF, amplitude transfer
function.
So this-- if you do
have just a Fourier
transform of this convolution,
you get a product.
And so this is saying
that the spectrum out--
the spatial frequency
content of the image
is equal to the
spatial frequency
content of the input
multiplied by some transfer
function, which is the Fourier
transform of the point spread
function.
Right, so this thing here is
called our amplitude transfer
function.
So we have to multiply the
spectral content of the object
by the transfer function.
And then we could do an
inverse Fourier transfer
and we'd end up
now with the image,
the amplitude in the image.
That there's something.
It wrote something, did it?
Yeah, OK.
Right, so we've already
[? reached ?] that.
OK, so let's look at these
examples we said again.
So these are two pupil masks
that we looked at before.
The first one is just
a low pass filter,
lets through the low
spatial frequencies
but doesn't let through the
high spatial frequencies.
And this was another--
this was a phase
filter we looked at
before where we only
let through the spatial
frequencies within this region.
But also within that region,
we changed the phase--
the relative phase
of the components
which are in this region here.
Right, so you can
think of this as being
the modulus of the filter.
This is the phase of the filter.
And outside here, of
course, it's zero anyway.
So [AUDIO OUT]
Right and then, this
is how we calculate the
transfer function from this.
This is a distance, right?
The pupil is actually
a real physical thing.
So it's got a physical size.
So this is measured
in centimeters here.
It cuts off at 1.5 centimeters.
And in order to convert
that into spatial frequency,
we have to divide
that by lambda f.
And this is putting
in some figures.
That says that u is equal to
x double dash in centimeters
times 10 to the
minus 3 centimeters
to the minus [AUDIO OUT]
[? Scaling ?] of our transfer
function, and then finally
this is what the ATF is.
5 is going to be 1.5
times 10 to the 3 cent--
[AUDIO OUT] which is what this
shows here in this diagram.
It's identical, just scaled.
Of course, to the
other example--
or any [AUDIO OUT]
[INAUDIBLE] [AUDIO OUT]
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE] is going
to have this modulus of phase
components.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Your sound is
breaking up a little bit.
And I wanted to ask how is the
point spread function related
to ATF?
Is it just the--
ATF is the Fourier transform
of the point spread function.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they're
a Fourier transform pair.
Yeah, but you have to be
careful with the scalings.
OK, so I don't
know why the sound.
I moved that a bit closer.
Is it?
TA: Maybe clip it
on the other side.
PROFESSOR: I'll clip it on
the other side, perhaps.
Right, OK.
Let's see if that's better.
Maybe just walking around.
OK, so that's that one finished.
Where am I going to
find something, George?
TA: [INAUDIBLE] That's proper.
PROFESSOR: OK, so now
we're up to today.
OK, so really today we're
going to carry on talking
about the same sort of stuff.
I think this is the
simplest way to describe it.
And so what we've
been looking at-- this
is just revising
again with the fact
that we're thinking
of the 4f system
as being a linear
shifting variance system.
Right, so if you remember
the shift invariance means
that the point spread function
is independent of position?
Right, so there in that case,
you can [? right ?] the image
as a convolution.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Mr. [INAUDIBLE]
There's [? nothing ?] with
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I hope that this is better.
So we can take about a 4f
system as being an linear shift
invariant imaging system.
And so this is
going through then
how you calculate
that sort of system.
So we start off with
some illuminating field
that comes in here.
It illuminates
some transparency.
And so what you get on
the far side of that
is going to be the
product of illumination
and the transparency.
All right, so this is
basically the object
of the imaging system,
And then it goes through
an imaging system
with a certain pupil
mask, which is related
to an amplitude
transfer function, which
is just a scaled version
of that pupil mask.
And by doing the Fourier
transform of that,
you will get the point spread
function of the system.
So the Fourier transform
of the pupil mask
gives this point spread
function like this.
And then your output
field is going
to be your input field
convolved with the point spread
function of the system.
So I noticed that--
so there are two versions of
this that are described here,
one in terms of x dashed,
and one in terms of x naught
dashed.
This x naught dashed
one is the rescaled one
to make it look like
a proper convolution.
So we've got rid of the
scaling factor F2 over F1.
And you see what
that does back here
in the point spread function
is it just changes an F2--
well, one over F2
to one over F1.
So you can work in
either of those.
There's no difference really.
OK, so let's now think about
how these concepts fit in
with what we learn from
geometrical optics.
And first of all, then we
look at natural magnification.
What we find then is that if
we have a point object here--
we just mentioned this before--
what it would give
is an image which
is going to be a blurred
image of a point object.
It's going to be this amplitude
point spread function.
But let's for the moment--
we're trying to find
out how this fits in
with the geometric optics limit.
Of course, in geometrical
optics there is no diffraction.
So you can look at the
sort of limiting case
as when that point
spread function becomes
a delta function.
So in this case,
this is not physical
because you couldn't do
this either very easily.
But you could do it only
by making the wavelength 10
to zero or you could
make the aperture 10
to infinity, which of
course, both things
you can't really do.
But just think of it like this
just to see what's going on.
If you could think of
the point spread function
as being a delta function,
the image of our point
here would be a point here.
And we've already found
where that point is.
We've found that
it's a point which
is on the opposite
side of the axis.
And the distance here is
scaled relative to this one
by the ratio of
the focal lengths.
And this is exactly what we
found from geometrical optics.
So the lateral magnification
is this n here.
nt is the lateral
magnification which
is given by minus the ratio of
the focal length in F2 over F1.
OK, so if we assume that
our amplitude point spread
function is just
a delta function,
then the output
amplitude is going
to be equal to the
input amplitude
but with this scaling.
OK, so that's the result we get.
It's exactly the same as you
get from geometrical optics.
Analyzing the same system
would also give you
this same magnification.
Right, so this is
another example.
This is looking at the angular
magnification of this system.
So before we looked
at what happens
for a point in the input plane.
Now we're going to look at
what happens to a plane wave
at a certain angle
in the input plane.
And you can see what that plane
wave does as it goes through.
Of course, the plane wave when
it's Fourier transformed now
becomes a converging wave,
which converges on this point.
It then spreads
again and then is
coming is collimated
by this lens
to produce an another
parallel wave there.
But you'll notice that
the angle of this wave
is not the same as the
angle of this wave.
For a start, you'll notice
they've got opposite signs.
That one's going up.
That one's coming down.
But that's what you'd
expect of course, because
of this same inversion that
we've been talking about.
So this input field then is
just an exponential face factor.
OK, so still assuming this
ideal geometrical point spread
function, the output field
is going to be given by this.
And you can then express
that in terms of phases.
And it comes out to be this.
So this is the angle--
the angle in was 3 to 1 and
the angle out is now minus F1
over F2 times 3 to 1.
So again, it's scaled and
got an inversion relative
to the input angle.
So you can see the
angle of magnification
then is given by this
expression, minus F1 over F2.
And again, that is
the same as you get
from your geometrical optics.
OK, so based on the
interpretation of propagation
of spatial frequency,
the magnification results
are also in agreement with
the scaling similarity
theorem of Fourier transforms.
Right, so you've got
an input amplitude,
an output amplitude related to
an input amplitude, an output
spatial frequency related to
an input spatial frequency.
And you notice this
one's got an F1 over F2.
And this one's
got an F2 over F1.
So this is back to where
idea is that if you make
the functions smaller,
the Fourier transform is
broader and vise versa.
OK, so now this geometry
I guess you could see--
maybe I could just draw one.
So this is our system.
And what I was going
to draw, this is F1.
F1, F1, F2, F2.
And you can see this wave
is coming in like this.
So we could have
drawn a ray like this.
And this would of course, have
been refracted so that it's
traveling parallel to the axis.
And then this would
come down like that.
So you can see here,
this is our phase one.
So f phase one is this distance.
And that is also--
if you think of this
as being theta out,
we can see that this distance
is the same as this distance.
And so F2 times theta out is
equal to F1 times theta in.
OK, so everything agrees
nicely with geometrical optics.
So that's good.
So let's look at
some examples now.
Let's look at some
examples of some apertures.
So first of all, the case of
let's put it as our pupil mask
a rectangular aperture, which
has got a distance a and b
in the two directions.
So we can think of this as being
rect, x over a times directive
rect of y over b.
And we can then work out what
the transfer function of that
is.
The transfer
function-- we said--
is just equal to a scaled
version of the pupil mask.
So if this is a rectangle,
this is also a rectangle.
But the scaling has got
this lambda F1 coming in.
Right, so this is now--
because it has to
have something.
This is a function of distance.
Sorry, x is distance.
a is distance.
Right, so this is the
dimension and its quantity.
And in here, this is distance.
This is distance.
And this is distance.
So this has to be, of course,
inverse distance, doesn't it--
to make this whole
thing dimensionless.
So this is why you need
to have something in there
to get it the right dimensions.
And then the point
spread function
is given by the Fourier
transform of that.
And that's what this looks like.
Fourier transform
of rect is sinc.
So this is separable.
So you just do the two
Fourier transforms separately.
And you end up with this
pattern that you've seen before.
It looks like a central spot
and then a lot of extra spots
that decrease in
amplitude or intensity
as you get away from that.
Yeah?
TA: Maybe we mentioned
that in the notes
that they posted the ATF
and PSF were mislabeled.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
In the notes that
were on the web,
this said PSF and this said ATF.
So it's pretty obvious
when you see them.
It's obviously the
wrong way around.
TA: And we posted corrections.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
[? George ?] posted
a correction.
Now I was going to
ask one question.
This is presumably the intensity
of the point spread function
that your plotting here--
TA: Is the square.
PROFESSOR: Is the square.
Yeah, the square of the
amplitude point spread
function.
Right, So that's our first
example, very important
example.
The second one is probably
even more important.
So this is a circular aperture.
And of course, most
optical systems
do have circular apertures.
So this is why this is
of great importance.
It seems to have
turned out being
bit like American football for
some reason, but never mind.
And practice because it's going
to over to the US, I suppose.
TA: This would have been
OK except the perception
[INAUDIBLE] the
other way around.
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
That's true.
Yes.
It doesn't know how to do
Fourier transforms obviously.
Anyway, this is
supposed to be a circle.
And if this is the
pupil mask, the transfer
function-- the amplitude
transfer function is just
a scaled version of this.
So it's again just
a circular thing.
And sorry, perhaps I just
ought to stress this.
It's obvious to you now,
I'm sure, by this stage.
So this is plotted
here as black or white.
Of course, white means one--
black means zero in this case.
So that means if spatial
frequencies land on this, those
inside this get through
and those outside this
don't get through, right?
So this is what we have
to multiply our frequency
response of our object by in
order to get the frequency
response of the image.
And that's just like before.
We have to scale this
with these lambda F1s.
And then the Fourier
transform of this
will give the point
spread function.
And this one has now gone
into glorious technicolor.
And so this is what
we call the airy disc.
The equation for best is given
in terms of Bessel functions.
You've defined this at
some point, I presume.
I'm not sure I was in the
lecture where we defined
this [INAUDIBLE] function, which
is basically 2j 1 of something
over something.
And so this is our
normal airy disc,
the image of a
point object, which
has got this central
bright spot, and then
a dark ring, and then some
bright rings outside a not so
bright ring, and then another
dark ring, and so on and so on.
All right, so what
we find then is
the size of this has got this
magic factor 1.22 that comes up
all the time in terms of when
you look at Rayleigh resolution
and things, you always
get this magic factor,
which is actually 3.83 which
is the first zero of J1 divided
by pi it turns out.
So that's why you get
this magic figure.
OK, and this is just to
remind you of course,
when it comes to
resolution, we've
mentioned before
how resolution is
related to numerical aperture.
And so what we're doing
here is producing an image
of an object, aren't we?
So if we've got an
object, it's imaged
with this lens, which has got
a certain numerical aperture.
Right, so this
aperture here is what
decides the resolution
of the image
that you will get
in this system.
This aperture here,
you see is a ray that
was drawn so it goes to the
edge of this pupil mask.
And if you trace
this strobe, you'll
see that it comes
back down here.
Sorry, of course, the numerical
aperture is actually--
the sine of this
angle, if you remember.
That's what this means.
It's not the angle itself.
NA is not the angle.
NA is equal to N sine
alpha, if you remember.
The refractive index
of the material
times the sine of this angle.
But what we find is that
if F1 and F2 are not equal,
this angle here,
of course, is not
going to be equal to this one.
You can see that if NA
is small, if NA is small,
you can see that
these are going to be
scaled in the same way
as your F1 and your F2.
It [INAUDIBLE] exactly be that.
Of course, this NA would
have to be the tan of that.
But the sine-- if NA is
small, then this distance
is the same here and here.
So this distance
over this distance
divided by this distance
is pretty close to being the
ratio of the focal length.
OK, so we've got a certain
NA on the input side.
And we've got a certain
NA on the output side.
And the ratio
between those names
is just equal to the
magnification of the system.
So actually, of course,
we're well used to the fact
that rays of light go equally
well in both directions.
So we could use this
same ray diagram
to look at what happens
if this was the object
and this was the image.
But in this case, of course, all
these things are now inverted.
So if it was producing--
as it stands here, it's
producing a demagnified image
in this way.
So it would produce a
magnified image going this way.
And so you see that the object
that you'd have to be imaging
is scaled relative to this one.
So the resolution would
be the same basically
in two directions.
I mean, sorry--
that's not quite true.
What am I trying to say?
I'm trying to say that the
NA relative to the size
of our object that
we're imaging here
will be the same when
we think of it as going
this way or that way,
because in real terms, how
small a thing you can actually
see with an optical system
depends on the numerical
aperture of the lens
that you're looking at with,
not the lens at the far end.
OK, and then for
our slit aperture,
this is what the point
spread function looks like.
And then you can express
that then very simply just
replacing our a over F1
by numerical aperture,
we've got now that
the width at this spot
is given by lambda
over NA, which
is exactly what we came about--
I guess you said that
before somewhere.
TA: I can't remember.
PROFESSOR: But the
resolution of a microscope
or whatever and of
an imaging system,
you can write in this form.
So of course, this
distance will be
smallest when this is biggest.
So the biggest this
could be is if NA was one
and you made n, the
refractive index nice and big.
And this one, these
distances are in terms--
this is distance in
the image in terms
of the NA in the output plane.
So you could have
converted this so this
is distance in the objects.
And then this would become
NA in the input plane.
And right and then
circular aperture,
our point spread
function looks like this.
And so this is what we get.
And this delta r dashed here
given by this expression,
this 0.61 is half of
the 1.22 we had before.
But notice this
is delta r dashed
is the radius of
the PSF [INAUDIBLE]
So it's this distance,
not the whole distance.
It's this distance, right?
So this is why we got half--
why the 1.22 is divided by 2.
OK.
Now I didn't mislead you
also by saying from now
to the end of the lecture's
a breeze because it
isn't, because the next bit
is this thing about sampling.
So that one more bit which is
a bit difficult to take in.
And this is really pointing out
about effectively the number
of degrees of
freedom in an image.
So imagine first of all,
you've got an object
that you're imaging.
So this is this input field.
It's got a certain size
which is called here delta x.
And of course, in any
real practical systems,
you don't actually measure
it as a continuous function.
It's actually going
to be measured
with a certain pixel size.
So here we're calling
the pixel size delta x.
Right, now so what
we've got here then
is this function is
like an array of spikes
in this direction.
An array of spikes delta
functions in this direction,
isn't it--
so in the products of those.
And if you do the Fourier
transform of that,
you'll get something which is
very similar again an array
of spikes.
If you look in the standard
books on Fourier transforms
like Bracewell or whatever,
he calls this a cone function.
And the Fourier transform
of a cone function
is another cone function.
Right, so this is a cone array
of delta functions multiplied
by a rectangle.
And the Fourier
transform of a product
is the convolution of
the Fourier transforms.
Right, so the Fourier transform
of the rect is actually--
so this is really--
I ought to get into that.
So just think of this then as
being in the spatial frequency
domain.
It's got a certain range
of spatial frequencies,
and it's made up of certain
resolution of frequencies.
So what we're going to say is
something about Nyquist now.
So we can say that--
we know that in order to image
this input field, knowing
what this bandwidth
is here, we have
to sample with this distance.
Is that what I'm trying to say?
Yeah.
The bandwidth is equal to 1 over
twice the sampling distance.
That's right.
Yeah, and this is
in the x direction.
This is in the y direction.
But we can also--
you can see by the similarity
of these diagrams and the fact
that Fourier transforms
go either way,
you can see that there will be
a similar sort of Nyquist type
criterion going from
the other way around.
So because this has
got a finite field,
this would mean that you've
got a certain frequency
resolution there.
So there's a relationship
between delta u and delta x.
The fact that this
has got a 2 here,
of course, you know from the
normal definition of Nyquist.
And the fact that this
one doesn't have a 2 in,
it just comes
about from the fact
that this is defined here
as being two times this.
And right, so just like before,
the spatial frequency domain--
those spatial
frequencies are then
multiplied by the pupil mask
to find the spatial frequencies
in the image, aren't they?
Right, so this is looking now
in the plane of the pupil mask.
So this is actually the same
as equal to this but just
with a rescaling.
And so these are the
expressions for that.
So this is just applying that
rescaling, putting these lambda
F1s in these expressions.
So you'll get then
what you need,
how you need to sample
in this plane here.
And what you can notice
from that is if you
you'll notice that these
things are all equal and equal
to some constant, therefore.
And this thing is called
the Space bandwidth product.
So you look at what this means.
Delta x over delta
x is the field size
divided by the pixel size.
So it's basically the number of
pixels in the field, isn't it?
Right, so your
original object here
has got the number of pixels
equal to n x times n y.
So that's the total amount
of the number of pixels.
And therefore if you think of
it as being a binary thing,
it's the amount of
information that you've
got in that original object.
And of course,
that information is
going to be transferred
through the system.
So if you look at now the ratio
in the next plane in terms
of use, this distance
over this distance
is equal to again,
the number of pixels.
And as you know, when you
do a fast Fourier transform
of something which
has got n elements,
you get something
which is n elements.
So it all works right.
So effectively, you can think
of this as being a bit like--
of course, you can't really--
if this has actually got
some finite bandwidth, then
of course you can't
sample on points.
So it's a bit of an idealization
to thinking this for the terms
really.
But nevertheless, it
gives you a good idea.
So of course, for a repetitive
type function like this,
also you can think in
terms of a Fourier series
becomes a Fourier transfer.
Right, so all we're
doing here is really
resolving our function
here into a Fourier series.
And the Fourier series consists
of a lot of sine terms,
doesn't it?
Sine of n, and sine
of x, and sine of 2x,
and so on and so on, and these
correspond in the Fourier
domain to these
points on this grid.
Right, so these
each of these points
represents the particular
Fourier series component
in the original object if
you think of it like that.
So the idea of a space
bandwidth product
is quite a powerful
way of thinking
about the fundamental
limits of an optical system.
And people have gone on to
study this sort of approach
in much more detail,
actually trying
to get around the limitations
that I just described.
The fact that, of course,
that we've truncated this
means that this is no longer
a repetitive function.
And similarly for here, right?
So that actually you know
this idea of thinking
of truncated
repetitive functions
is a bit of a anomaly, really.
But people have come up
with mathematical ways
of dealing with these sorts
of systems which are probably
way beyond what we are going
to get to in this course.
OK, did something come up then?
Oh, yeah.
Next slide.
So OK, this is just
pointing out then
we said that you
put a mask in here
and that mask produces a
certain transfer function--
amplitude transfer function, and
the Fourier transform of that
gives the pupil function.
And we've shown a
couple of examples
of what this pupil
function looks like
and what the image
would look like.
But this is just pointing
out that actually,
of course, that means that
we can choose whatever
we want to put in there in order
to produce the results we want.
So this is what
George has called here
pupil engineering, which Ernst
Stelzer doesn't believe in,
I think, from what
we were saying.
But anyway, so the idea is
that by changing this mask,
you can improve the properties
of that point spread function
in some way, which would suit
the that particular application
you're looking at.
Actually, it turns out
that you can't actually
do a lot better normally
than the very simple example
of a circular aperture.
And the circular aperture
is actually very special
because it does give according
to some measures anyway, a very
sharp point spread function.
And you can come up with
other pupil functions
that make the central lobe
narrower, but normally
what happens is then the size
of the side lobes get stronger.
So it's a sort of compromise.
You can't have a very
small central lobe together
with very weak side lobes.
OK, so some examples then.
So let's imagine first
of all, our object
is our intensity
at the input plane
is this rectangle with
the stripy pattern.
And so we're going
to then look at what
happens if we image that with
some mask that we put in here.
And what should we
put in there, then?
Well, the first one let's
put in something like this.
So now this is going
to let through--
this is a low pass
filter, isn't it?
Right, so it's a very small
low pass filter as well.
So it only lets through the
very slowly varying parts
of that object.
But it stops all the fast
variations of the object.
Right, so if you
look at the object,
you'll see that it's got
this stripy pattern, which is
actually a very fine structure.
So these are
actually really being
calculated using Mat lab,
not by me, by George.
And so this is what you'd see
in the output plane of that.
So there you are.
You can see that
this stripy pattern
has disappeared virtually.
We've lost some
sharpness at the edge
though because we've also lost
the high spatial frequencies,
of course, that
defined the edge.
And a sharp cut off at the
edge will include quite a lot
of high spatial frequencies.
But anyway, so that's a good
example of spatial filtering.
And then the next
ones we're going
to look at something which
has got a bit more structure.
And so this is MIT
written as a binary mask.
And so this is our
original object.
And we're going to image
that in an optical system
and look at what the image
looks like in different cases.
So the first one is
quite straightforward.
We've got now a
circular aperture.
So this is what the image
looks like in this case.
You see that there's already a
bit of artifacts in that image.
It's no longer-- you can
still read it as MIT,
but you see that
inside the letters,
you'll see there's
some structure there,
which is not really present.
So this is some sort of edge
ringing, I guess from the fact
that this aperture has
got this sharp cut off
at some particular
spatial frequency.
So if you made it so that
it tailed off gradually,
you could probably get
rid of some of that--
those fringes there.
But OK, so that's an aperture.
So we've got rid of some
high spatial frequencies.
Let's look what happens if we
reduce the spatial frequencies
even more.
So this is making
the aperture smaller.
And now you can see that
the resolution has degraded.
It looks rather blurry now.
You can you can't
really see whether it
says MIT of HIT or maybe HIY.
It's all getting a
bit vague, isn't it?
And also you can see that
it gets a bit sort of blurry
around the edges.
Yeah, sorry if we make that--
AUDIENCE: Question?
One thing to point out here
which is kind of obvious,
but it's worth pointing is
that if you do this also,
the average brightness
of the image
would decrease as you
stop down the aperture.
But in this case, they cheated.
They normalized the
intensity to the full level
so it is visible
in the projector.
But in a real system, it
would also become less bright.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK so I
didn't notice that because I
didn't do the calculations.
But yeah, OK.
So of course, if this aperture
gets smaller and smaller,
the amount of
light going through
gets smaller or smaller.
And so in the end,
you'd end up with black.
Right, so anyway we're now
going to make this even smaller.
So what would you expect?
Well, you'd expect
that again the thing
to become more blurry looking.
And in fact, it
really does become.
Just before we carry on,
just take this fully in.
You notice that there are four
legs here, four straight lines.
And these two are
closer together
than these other
spacings, right?
So as we decrease the
size of the pupil,
now you see what's happened.
This is quite amazing.
I was quite surprised at this.
The four legs have
become three legs.
So I guess these two central
legs are now not resolved.
They're below the
resolution limit.
And you'd have no idea of
course what that said now.
It looks something
really blurred.
So we're not getting enough
information obviously there
to be able to see
the image properly.
OK, then let's try doing
some other funny things.
So this one is a
high pass filter.
Now, so what we're
doing here is we're
blocking out this
central part and letting
through all the other filters,
all the other frequencies.
Now there's one
other thing that we
ought to mention here is that
this, of course, is done--
these calculations are
done using FFTs, right?
So we're actually working
on a field of a certain size
when we calculate the FFTs.
The fact that this--
as you know FFTs do like a
sort of repeating, don't they?
Right, so this is not really
quite the same as this being
going out to infinity
in spatial frequency.
So I think that the result
in the image you might get
could depend a little on the
properties of the zero padding
and things like
that in this case.
But anyway, this is
the image in this case.
So you'll notice that we've got
the high spatial frequencies.
So we actually get some sort
of enhancement of the edges.
You see the edges come out
really very crisply now.
So you get this
enhancement of the edges.
It's like an edge
enhancement filter.
But on top of that, there's
a rather strange sort
of glowing patterns,
which I'm not really quite
sure what they refer to at all.
But you could-- I
guess-- think of them
as being some sort of artifact.
It looks a lot better on
this screen than that one.
Interesting.
But if we do another of
these high pass filtering
but with the central
block even bigger,
this effect of edge enhancement
shows really nicely now.
So all we're now
seeing is the edges.
And the bits inside the letters
are not showing up or outside
the letters, so neither.
I can't remember what the
object looked lie now.
It's interesting.
The object, whether
it was black writing
on a white background
or white writing
on the black background,
probably this
would look very similar.
It wouldn't make a
lot of difference--
I don't think.
OK, and so all these examples
have been circularly symmetric
type patterns.
But you can also, of
course, put in things which
are not certainly symmetric.
So this is throwing out these
frequencies here and here.
So we haven't done
anything here.
So we're going to have a high
resolution in that direction.
But in this direction here,
we've reduced the resolution.
So we'd expect it to be blurred
in the vertical direction.
And of course, just to prove
that we can do the opposite,
and this one now is
going to be blurred
in the horizontal direction.
So you see here
again, you're almost
losing the resolution
of those four legs.
OK, and then probably one of
the most important applications
of pupil filters is
in phase imaging.
And so this leads on to
a Zernike face contrast,
which Zernike got
the Nobel Prize for.
It's quite interesting.
It was a long time after he
invented it though, I believe.
He invented it
sometime in the '30s.
And it was commercialized--
actually he seems
to have managed
to get Zeiss and [? Leicher ?]
and everyone to make it.
So he must have sold his
patent to lots of people.
But anyway, eventually
it became very popular.
But it didn't get it didn't get
the Nobel Prize until the '50s
some time.
And very useful
for a long time, I
think eventually it
got to a certain degree
anyway, outclassed by
some later techniques,
but still used a
fair bit in the lab.
He has one advantage of
being quite cheap as well.
Anyway, what you're trying to do
with [? phase-phase ?] contrast
is image of phase objects.
And this is an example of what
a phase object might look like.
Imagine, for example, you've
got some glass slide--
well, one thing which would
approximate quite well to this
is if you had a
biological cell sitting
on top of a glass slide.
Right, so this shows
that something like that.
But actually what
we're thinking--
well, if it was a
cell, of course,
the refractive index
of this would be
slightly different from this.
But that's really not
an important difference.
So this is looking
on the top of it.
So here we've got
this object, which
has got a certain thickness.
And what we'd like
to be able to do
is to produce an image
which actually shows up
the shape of this
object, right, which
might be a cell or something.
And so this phase object--
we can think of the light
propagating through this
and producing a
phase shift then.
So the phase shift is
given by this expression.
So n here is the refractive
index of this cell.
We have to have n minus 1, of
course, because the cell is
displacing air.
So the cell wasn't there,
there would be air there.
So we have to subtract away the
air that would have been there.
And so the phase is 2
pi times n minus 1 times
the thickness, which is a
function of x or of x of y
in this case, divided
by the wavelength.
And so if we illuminate this
with some certain illumination
field this, then what we'll
get on the output side
is just this times this.
There's no-- each of
the i phi, our object
just behaves here as
a pure phase object.
There's no modulus change,
only a phase change.
Yeah, so useful for
imaging biological objects
such as cells,
but not only that.
It's got applications in
material science, and so on.
And yeah, so if
we looked at the--
image this illumination
is just unity.
And we look at the
modulus squared
of this object function.
You see, because it's
just only a phase object,
when you look at
the modulus square,
you'll see nothing at all.
So if you look at this in
an ordinary microscope,
you wouldn't see anything.
You'd just see completely
uniformly white.
And so you wouldn't see
the shape of this thing
that we're trying to see.
So the question is, how
can we go about that?
What can we do to solve that?
So yeah, what we're
now going to look at
is back to this MIT pattern.
And we're going
to think of an MIT
pattern, which is now not
a binary object but a phase
object.
So imagine that
this is our object.
So this represents phase.
So red represents a phase
change of 0.1 of a radian.
And this one shows the modulus
of this object, which we're
assuming is completely uniform.
And so it's a pure phase object.
And if we looked at this in
our ordinary optical imaging
system, all we'd see is the
modular square of this thing.
So we'd see basically nothing.
So the question is what can
we do to try and improve that.
Well, Zernike came
up with the answer.
And actually, this is not
quite the way he does it.
We're not going to really
do the way he does it.
But the principle
is here anyway.
What you do is you introduce
a pupil mask, which has also
got a phase objects in it.
It's got basically
a small region
at the center, i.e. where the
low spatial frequencies are,
which we change
the relative phase
of those spectral components
relative to the other spatial
frequencies by pi over 2.
And so we put that
in our in our system.
And what we find,
as it says there,
is we can actually get
contrast of the phase.
We actually see the phase now.
And this will explain
why that works.
So this is what we're doing.
We're putting in our
phase MIT thing here.
And we're putting in this
pi over 2 phase mask here.
So that's what it looks like.
It's some bit of
dielectric, which
has got this
central region which
changes the phase by pi over 2.
Ideally, what we want
to do, as it says here,
is for this to be very small.
What we're trying
to do is to use
it to change the phase
of just the DC component,
the unscattered light component
relative to all the rest.
But of course, you can
never do that because it's
got to have some
definite real size.
So whatever size
it is, there might
be some low spatial frequencies
of the object, which
are going to be--
the phase is going
to be changing
in the same way as the DC term.
So let's look at the
mass of how that works.
So what we do is we assume
our phase object is what
we call a weak phase object.
It's got the form
e to the i phi.
But we think of that as being
approximately one plus i phi.
And we neglect all
the other higher order
terms in the Haus's series
expansion for the exponential.
And you can see then that in an
ordinary system, what we'd see
is you can think of it--
keeping all the terms,
the modular square of this
is obviously one.
And this also,
the modular square
of this to the first
order of small quantities
is also going to be one.
Of course, if you square this,
you'll get phi squared terms.
But actually, there
are also really
some extra phi squared terms
in this series, which actually,
if you do it properly,
all cancel out.
So you still must get one.
OK, so what we're now going
to say, this is our object.
But now, this object is going
to go through this mask here,
which is going to change the
relative phase of this relative
to this.
And so if we change
the one to i,
we're not going to
get i plus i phi.
And therefore now,
the output that we get
is going to be given by--
this should be into
i, intensity actually.
Yeah, the intensity that you
see is the modular square
of this, which is 1 plus phi
squared, which to small--
Because phi is small,
we can expand that
to first two terms
of the series.
And we get one plus two phi.
Right, so now we're getting
an image where the phase is
visible to the order of this--
order of the weak
phase object phi.
In this case here, we
weren't seeing anything
to the order of phi.
The lowest things
that were there
would be of the order
of phi squared, which
is going to be negligible if
phi is going to be small enough.
Right, so there we are.
So by putting this
in, we've managed
to make this phase
object visible.
So this is the
demonstration of that.
So this is our looking
out at our phase MIT.
And this is the size
of our phase mask.
So it's quite big here actually.
And so I guess, it's changing
the phase of the central DC
term.
But it's also changing the phase
of some low spatial frequency
terms of the MIT,
which I guess accounts
for some sort of
imperfections in this image.
And I think a lot
of the ripples--
again, are coming from
the fact that this
has got a sharp edge to it.
Probably if you
smoothed this, you
could make it so that you
didn't get such a strong ringing
in this thing here.
But this is the next example.
We've now made
this a lot smaller.
So it's now changing the
phase of the DC term.
But it seems that the
object itself probably
has got very, very weak
components in that region.
And you end up then with
this really wonderful image.
So I guess that really shows
the power of the Zernike phase
contrast method.
That's the end.
How are we going?
Good, we're up to time.
I've been fast.
Right, any questions anywhere?
Anyone want to look at
these nice pictures again?
AUDIENCE: We had a
question actually.
PROFESSOR: Yes good.
AUDIENCE: It seemed like the
last analysis you're doing,
phi was much, much less than 1.
But then you're saying
that phi was pi over 2.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
Two different phi's.
How do I get back in this?
TA: You click the play button.
PROFESSOR: The play button.
Ah, the play button.
It's right there.
Yeah, OK.
So two different phi's.
The object is the one
that has to be weak.
So here we said the
object has got this phi.
So we got e to the
i phi as the object.
And this phi has to be small.
And somewhere it said--
maybe it was after.
The phase MIT objects--
here we are.
the phrase change
is 0.1 of a radian.
So 0.1 of a radian we're
taking as being small.
But so red here represents
0.1 of a radian.
Red there doesn't
represent 0.1 of a radian.
So this is our mask.
So this has got a phase
change of pi by 2.
So this is much bigger
than 0.1 of a radian.
OK?
Yeah, so that's-- it's the
object that has to be a weak
phase object, not the mask.
TA: I think the principle still
works for strong phase objects.
But the explanation is easier if
you assume a weak phase object.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think I agree with that.
Yeah, but actually for
a strong phase object,
you do also get an image in
your ordinary imaging system.
But it's very complicated
to actually relate it
to the object.
It's a bit like
frequency modulation.
TA: Or another example
of a strong phrase object
is the waves in a swimming pool.
They create an image
at the bottom which
looks like very bright lines.
In a way these
lines are an image
of the index of
reflection of the water.
And these lines are
known as caustics.
But it is very difficult to
interpret them and relate them
to the actual
shape of the water.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, any more questions?
Not many from this
end, today, either.
I usually rely on [INAUDIBLE]
to come up with some questions.
You know, at FOM, he
was in FOM, and he
asked the very first question
of the whole conference.
TA: Oh, that is quite
the distinction.
To the plenary
speaker, I imagine?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, to
the plenary speaker.
All very clear?
I think these
demonstrations are really
great because I think that you
get a very nice feel for what
happens.
TA: We have the quiz coming up.
But we have enough time.
Maybe we can introduce
temporal coherence
at the beginning
of the next lecture
or should we just stop here?
PROFESSOR: Up to you.
TA: If anybody has no questions
at all, we have quiz coming up.
This is your chance to
ask questions, I suppose.
PROFESSOR: So when's the quiz?
TA: On Monday.
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
OK.
TA: That's why he could
not answer the question.
He was expecting a phone call.
AUDIENCE: When you
have a phase grading,
normally you try to solve for a
system that has the 4f system,
you normally play
different tricks.
One of them is you try to expand
part of the grading in Fourier
series.
And after that,
you somehow managed
to decompose that
into something easy,
or you actually change the e
to the exponent to something
easier to handle in terms
of you look at the phase--
and you look at it.
And if it is like pi
over two or it's pi,
you change it to
something different
that it's easier to handle, any
advice on how to solve those?
I found those
particularly tricky
to actually get a grasp
of how to solve things.
PROFESSOR: I'm not quite
sure you're saying.
I mean if you've got--
I mean, you start off
by saying you've got
some sort of gradient object.
And then if you
illuminate this, you'll
get a series of
diffraction orders.
And of course, you know, the
relative strengths of these
might be complex to account
for the phase changes.
And so what you're saying is
that by changing the phrase
or whatever of these components,
you can improve the image.
But is that what you're saying?
Something like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my
question was more
in the order of like
how to handle the math?
Normally if you get something
in terms of Fourier series,
you get a bunch of terms.
And it's kind of like it
ends up being pretty messy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But you know, this is like
going through the mask.
So if we've got some mask which
has got some phase variation.
So the relative strength
of these gradient orders,
it will just be changed by
the phase of the phase mask.
So the forward problem--
I've got the feeling
that maybe you
were trying to solve the
inverse problem, you know.
If you know what the
image looks like,
how do you know how
to improve the image
or something like that?
But normally, of course, if
you knew what the object was,
then it probably wouldn't be
a lot of point in imaging it.
But anyway, to calculate this,
this is all you have to do.
Just multiply the strength
of these gradient components
by the strength of your mask,
both in amplitude and phase.
So it's very
straightforward really.
TA: And I don't think there's
a way out of the Fourier series
expansion.
Like if you really want to
solve this kind of a problem
with a phase gradient, you
must compute the Fourier series
expansion of the gradient.
Unless, for example,
if the phase is weak,
then you can simplify it as
we just saw in the example.
But otherwise,
yeah, you have to go
through the pain of the
Fourier series expansion.
OK, thanks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But you know, there are
some times of course,
for lots of other objects,
you can just look them up
in the tables of
Fourier transforms.
And even the Fourier
series, you can sometimes
get from that, of course.
I mean, for example, you
know, these square wave
gradients like this.
You can think of this as being
this convolved with this.
So the Fourier
transform of this is
going to be the Fourier
transform of this, which
is a sinc times the
Fourier transform of this,
which is another one of these.
Right, so you end up with
basically an envelope,
which is this and then some
components within here.
And the height of
these gives you
the strengths of these
different gradient components.
So I think there was a
sketch like that in one
of the earlier slides showing
how you can think of that.
So these are the
strengths of the Fourier
series for this object.
They're just given
by the product
of a sinc and an appropriately
scaled sampling function.
TA: I think you need to push
the paper a little bit up.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Yeah.
Can I do that?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
There you can see
what I'm saying.
Yeah, so some
sometimes you can find
shortcuts to be able
to deal with some
of these various
areas without having
to go through that the hard
work of doing what you did when
you were a first year student.
TA: There was a homework like
that actually where it was not
quite phrased like
this-- but yeah,
I had you guys
compute the Fourier
series in this clever way.
PROFESSOR: OK no more questions.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE] got one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How did the idea of
numerical aperture come about?
And why is it defined
as a sine of an angle?
PROFESSOR: Rather the
tangent of an angle.
Yeah, good point.
Well, I guess it's because
George in one of the earlier
lectures pointed out that
according to Snell's law,
you've got n sine
alpha is the invariant.
So as rays goes through
a series of interfaces,
then that will be an invariant.
It won't change.
So I think that was the
justification for it.
But yeah, you've hit
something which is quite--
you know, the fact that
sine theta isn't tan theta
is basically why paraxial
optics eventually breaks down.
And so a lot of the stuff
that we've presented
has been based on assuming that
these angles are all small.
And a lot of these
things just fail
if you can't assume that
these angles are small.
TA: For example,
aberrations are another type
of not shift invariant
behavior with the exception
of spherical.
But the aberrations
are not shift invariant
so our approximations fail.
For example, astigmatism
if you recall,
astigmatism occurs if you have
a plane wave entering the lens--
I'm sorry, I
should've said coma.
Coma occurs if you have
a plane wave entering
the lens at an angle.
So of course, as you
increase the angle,
the coma becomes worse.
So that is shift invariant
PROFESSOR: OK, do you
want to stop or do
you want to say something?
TA: We could talk
about the Talbot effect
that we skipped in
the previous lecture.
I can have to do to find it.
PROFESSOR: I think that might
not be interested in that
because I don't think
my students have ever
come across the Talbot effect.
[INAUDIBLE] I was
just going to say--
[INAUDIBLE] that's all right.
I'll come and say it here.
I was just going to say
that this Talbot effect.
He was actually a
very long time ago.
I can't quite
remember the history,
but it's a very old effect.
TA: And I think Talbot was also
another professor of mechanics
who ended up doing contributions
in optics if I'm not mistaken,
very similar to Maxwell and
a bunch of other people.
No, no.
I went the other
way around there.
I shouldn't be expected to make
the contributions in mechanics.
[INAUDIBLE] OK, oh, I'm
not showing anything.
I'm sorry.
So the Talbot effect
is a phenomenon
that happens when we have a
periodic pattern, for example
a gradient and you illuminate
it with a plane wave.
And then what you do is you
observe the intensity pattern
forming after the
field diffracts,
after it has gone
through the transparency.
So I don't when the
movie will show possibly
because of something
[INAUDIBLE] the projector,
it might not show.
But if you look
carefully, you will
see that as the field diffracts,
the original grate and pattern
becomes visible at
certain distances.
Then it disappears.
Then it becomes visible again.
It will play it in the
case of diagonal gradient
and then I will play
both of them again.
So you can see, it diffracts,
then the sinusoid reappears
and so on.
In this case, it is
actually very clear
when it will stop happening
because as we said,
in the case of a
gradient, in the field
after the gradient splits
up into diffraction orders.
Now this gradient is finite, so
as you can see the diffraction
orders separate.
And by the time it
reached here, you
can see that you have basically
three rectangles that have
split up out of the gradient.
So the Talbot effect will stop
happening when the rectangles
completely separate.
It hasn't quite stopped yet.
But it can only
happen that region
of overlap between gradients.
OK, so the next--
let me play this once
again so you can see it.
So again, look out for the
repetition of the periodicity
of this pattern now.
And again for the next one.
I hope with this is
showing up also in Boston.
Here you can see it very
clearly on the projector.
OK, so yes?
OK, so the next slide
is cross sections?
AUDIENCE: George?
Did you see that this
effect occurs only
when there is an overlap between
the diffraction orders of the--
TA: Yes.
So if the gradient is
infinite, then, of course,
it occurs forever.
But if the gradient is
finite, eventually the orders
will separate and then
it doesn't happen.
So this is cross sections
of the intensity pattern
at different distances,
which of course I
chose strategically
because I know the formula
that this effect follows.
Of course, you don't
have the formula yet.
But anyway, this
is what you see.
Now what is really
interesting and you may not
have seen in the previous
one, but there's also
a plane where you see a periodic
pattern at twice the frequency.
So this like the second harmonic
of the original gradient.
So the question is
why does that happen.
Well, there is the physical
explanation, which is probably
the most interesting.
And that has to do
with the following.
So this really goes to
the heart of diffraction,
why really diffraction
happens and why
we see all of this phenomenon.
So imagine that you
have a plane wave going
into a sinusoid
amplitude gradient.
And of course, in this case
you only get three diffraction
orders, as we discussed,
the plus 1, the minus 1,
and the [INAUDIBLE]
And these diffraction
orders, each one of them
is really a plane wave.
So you have now--
you started with one coming
in, but after the gradient,
you have three plane
waves propagating out.
And imagine that you pick any
point of the gradient really,
it doesn't matter.
But let's pick this one.
And we'll draw a
sphere over radius z.
we'll draw a sphere
centered at this point.
Now if you compare
the three plane waves
and you take rays
really, centered
at the center of this
sphere, and if you
compare what happens to
these plane waves by the time
that each of the
cell of this sphere,
then you realize that they
all have the same phase delay
because they only propagated the
same distance from the center
to the edge of this sphere.
They all propagated
by the same amount.
So they have the
same phase delay.
However, when we
observe the field
in all of this cross-section
that I showed before
in my movie and in
the calculation,
I did not really observe
the field on a sphere.
I observed it on a plane.
So if a center this plane at
a distance z from the axis,
then the central order
that propagates a axis,
it sustains itself
in phase delay.
But you can see that the
plus one and minus one order,
they propagate the longer
distance from this sphere
to that gradient.
And you can calculate
this distance.
It is the difference
between the z itself
and an expansion that is that
you get from its Pythagoras's
theorem.
So this expression is basically
the hypotenuse of this triangle
all the way out to the plane.
And if you do after that
the paraxial approximation,
then you find that is
given by a quadratic.
That is this is our
familiar quadratic term that
appears in the Fresnel kernel
and in all of these expressions
of Fresnel diffraction.
So however, now what
am I really observing?
Well, in this plane, I observe
the interference pattern.
You can think of it as
a Fresnel diffraction
pattern from the
gradient or you can also
think of it as an interference
pattern between these three
plane waves.
It's like an
interferometer, right?
I mean, physically as I
think Professor separately
mentioned and I also mentioned
at some point or another,
diffraction is really no
different than interference.
It is just that in the
case of diffraction,
you have many, many, many
waves interfering produced
by the Huygen's
wavelengths originating
at your original object.
But in this case,
instead of thinking
of all these
Huygens wavelengths,
I'm better off just
thinking about it
as plane waves interfering
because the physics
of the gradient tell me that
the diffracting field is really
composed of three plane waves.
So now there's a phase delay
between this guy and this guy.
Actually, this guy and this
guy, the plus 1 and minus 1
are always in phase.
But they can have a
difference in phase delay
between the themselves
and the 0-th order.
And of course, if that phase
delay happens to be 2 pi,
then there's no phase delay.
And when did these things
start having no phase delay?
Well, at the gradient, right?
So if I let this thing
propagate enough, whatever
parameter I can vary here is z.
If I let z grow so that
this phase delay becomes
equal to 2 pi, then I
reproduced my original gradient
because of course, there
was no phase delay here.
So when the phase
delay becomes 2 pi,
then again I will
see the same pattern.
It is not as obvious why
you get the subharmonic, why
you get the second harmonic
that I discussed before.
But there is a
little bit fortunate
that the lectures got shuffled
in order because by now, you
remember from one of the
examples of Professor
Sheppard showed, when you
actually get rid of the DC
component, you can get
the second harmonic
to pop out all of a sudden.
A very similar thing happens
if you get the pi phase shift.
This pi phase shift can produce
a very distinct sub harmonic.
So this is that reason.
Now the rest, I will
actually not go through.
But there's a
mathematical-- well,
I can go through very
quickly, I guess.
There's a mathematical
way to derive it.
And it is also
described in Goodman.
And I also did it in the slides.
So if you start with
a grate with a field
after the gradient--
of course, you can express
it as a diffraction orders.
We did this before.
You can put it in a form the
field after the gradient.
We've done this before ask in
the context of the 4f system.
But mathematically,
it is really the same.
Each one of these
exponentials in the field
will produce a delta function.
Now, the question
is what happens
after the field propagates
by a certain distance.
So in order to do that, let me
show the Fresnel diffraction
again.
These we're familiar with.
We said many times that
Fresnel diffraction
is expressed as a
convolution that
has to do with the
Huygen's wavelengths
propagating and producing
spherical waves that
again interfere.
So the interference is expressed
as a convolution integral.
But because of the properties
of the Fourier transform,
if I take a Fourier transform
of the output field,
then it will be expressed
as a product of the Fourier
transform of the input field
times the Fourier transform
of this Fresnel kernel.
And I really am not
going to prove this.
But you can look up in Goodman's
book in the table of Fourier
integrals.
You can look up the
Fourier transform
of an expression like this one.
And you'll find that
it looks very similar.
This is a quadratic phase delay
It's a Fourier transform.
It also looks like a
quadratic phase delay.
But it has two key differences.
One is that it has a minus sign.
So it is actually quadratic
phase advance if you wish.
And the second is, of course,
the [? scalene ?] theorem
that will take up this factor
of lambda z from the denominator
and will pop it up
in the numerator.
And of course, the happy
outcome of this scale operation
is that also the
units are preserved.
This quantity has
to be dimensionless.
So indeed, it is.
I have distance square
in the numerator
as well as the denominator.
In this case it uses
spatial frequency which
is inverse distance square.
By multiplying by
this distance squared,
I get again a one
dimensional quantity.
So the [? scalene ?]
theorem works quite nicely.
And you can also think then of--
we talked about
transfer functions
in the context
over the 4f system.
But really you can also
think of a transfer function
in the case of
Fresnel propagation
because it is shift invariant.
Clearly if you have free
space, that is it truly
a shift invariant system.
No matter where you
start in free space,
you would expect the field
to shift by the same amount.
It would be really odd if
anything else happened.
Unless you believe in space
and [INAUDIBLE] I guess.
Only close to the Big Bang,
this property was not observed.
But since billions of years
have lapsed since the Big Bang,
space is isotropic.
So we don't have
to worry about it.
So of course, the Fourier
integral approaches.
And of course, then this
quantity that we derive
is simply the transfer
function of free space.
It is another
quadratic phase delay.
OK, so we can actually
apply this formulation now
to the mathematics
of the Talbot effect.
All I have to do is multiply
the Fourier transform
of the gradient itself.
All I have to do is multiply
it with a Fourier transform
of the Fresnel
propagation kernel that is
another quadratic phase delay.
And this multiple
multiplication is very easy
to do because I'm
multiplying the function
that I know with a bunch
of delta functions.
So all that will remain
really is the value
of this quadratic phase
delay computed at the spots
where the delta
functions occurred.
And this is what I'm
doing the next slide.
This looks a little
bit nasty but really
that's all you need to know.
It looks like an expression
very similar to the gradient.
This is the DC component.
This is the plus one
diffracted order.
This is a minus one
But it picked up this additional
quadratic phase delay,
which is really it came
out of the math now.
I used Fourier transforms
and convolutions
and everything else.
But if you go back to my
picture here with the sphere
and the phase delays,
you can really
see that this is really
the same expression.
It came out of the
math in one case.
It really came out
of a physical picture
of phase delay of [? planes ?]
as they propagate.
But it's all consistent.
It is nearly all
the same answer.
And after a little
bit more pain,
which involves really taking
one Fourier transform,
and then combining these
things to form a sinusoid,
you'll get this
expression for the field.
And now you can see what I
was saying before, if you--
this looks like a
nasty phase delay
that got appended to
the diffracted field.
This is really
diffracted field now.
So this is the Fresnel
diffraction pattern
from a gradient.
But if this quantity and
exponent happens to be 2 pi,
then it is not there anymore.
So you recover your
original gradient.
OK, that's the intensity.
And you can also see
from this-- you can also
get the condition for the
second harmonic generation.
Basically, if you
kill this term, which
means that this quantity
becomes pi over 2,
then this disappears.
So all you're left is the cosine
squared, which is of course
the second harmonic.
So this is really delineated
in the next slide.
If the propagation distance--
if this quantity, this
is also non-dimensional.
It is distance squares
over distance squared.
If you propagate far
enough so that this equals
an even integer, then
you get the replica
of the original gradient.
This is basically--
this quantity
becomes a phase delay of 2 pi.
If you get it to become equal to
[? n, ?] you call this distance
a Talbot play.
If you're get it to propagate
so that it is an odd integer,
then it is pi that
shifts this term by pi.
Basically, you flip the sign.
Now the gradient has shifted.
If you really do work it out,
you still get the same sinusoid
but shifted by half a period.
And finally, if you completely
eliminate the linear term
by choosing--
this tends to be pi over 2 or
3 pi over 2 or 5 pi over 2,
and so on and so forth,
then you can actually get--
I forgot to put to
close my bracket here,
but anyway, then you
get the period doubled.
And you'll get the
second harmonic.
OK, and this the schematic.
These are basically now
repeating periodically
every time you add this
propagation distance--
I'm sorry, these
are flipped here.
This should have been 2 lambda
z over lambda squared, 2 lambda
z over lambda squared.
So basically every time you
propagate by this quantity,
you go from a Talbot
sub plane where
you have a second
harmonic to a half period
shift, to another second
harmonic to a replica.
And then it repeats.
So these are the Talbot plains.
Now we're out of
time so I will say
something that's
interesting for those
of you who have time to stay.
This-- as Professor
Sheppard mentioned
has been noticed since
a very long time ago.
But more recently, it became
actually kind of a hot topic
over [INAUDIBLE]
because people noticed
that it happens not only
in sinusoidal gradients,
but it can also happen in
every periodic pattern.
If, for example, you
have a square gradient,
it would also have
its own Talbot planes.
And then, not only
that, but people
noticed that it can happen
in some strange patterns that
are called was quasi-crystals.
So I don't know how many of you
have taken solid state physics.
But in solid state
physics they teach you
that there are certain
patterns in nature that--
there's often
symmetries in nature.
For example, a very
simple symmetries
is rectangular symmetry.
If you take this as a unit
cell and then you repeat it,
you can keep filling out the
space like this periodically.
Another example is a hexagon.
Let's see if I know
how to do the hexagon.
I ended up doing an octagon.
Sorry about that.
That's a pentagon.
I need one more, OK.
I got my hexagon, OK.
That's nice because
this does repeat.
OK, never mind anyway.
OK, that will repeat.
Good.
OK, so fortunately I
did a pentagon also.
So the question is
what will happen
if you start sticking
pentagons next to each other.
Now this will be really
impossible for me to do,
but you can imagine
if you tried to stick
another pentagon, identical
pentagon next to here,
then you will get something
like this, I guess.
And then you can keep doing it.
But you noticed when I did it,
then I got to stick a pentagon
but it is slightly rotated.
It is still is
difficult for me to draw
but if you google
quasi-crystals.
I don't know if it's the
first website that comes up.
There's a website at Caltech,
in the physics department
at Caltech.
And you will see some
very nice pictures
of what happens if you stick
pentagons next to each other.
That's called a quasi-crystal.
OK, now why are people
interested in this?
Physicists are interested
because in solid state
they teach you that if
you have atoms arranged
in one of the patterns that
produce symmetries, then
if you pass X-rays through
this symmetric lattice,
you get a diffraction
pattern, very
similar to a gradient
that we saw here,
except that we're in 3D
because the symmetries are
very simple in 2D.
I think in 2D you only get two--
you get the rectangular
and the hexagonal symmetry.
In 3D, you get many
more symmetries--
I forget, how many do you get?
I think it is 7 groups
or 12 or anyway.
I should refresh my
solid state physics.
But anyway, each one of
these gives rise to--
each symmetry gives rise to a
distinct diffraction pattern.
And then crystallographers
basically
bypass the next
stage to a crystal
and observe the
diffraction pattern--
they can guess what was
the original symmetry that
produced it.
We also know that non
symmetric patterns
can produce diffraction.
And that is what won Crick
and Watson the Nobel Prize
because they figured out
that you have a helix, which
not quite symmetric, it can
still produce a diffraction
pattern.
And Crick was a very clever
mathematician who solved it.
And he won the
Nobel Prize for it.
Anyway, recently people have
observed that quasi-crystals
like this one-- if
you take pentagons
and you stick them
next to each other,
they also produce a
diffraction pattern,
which looks actually
like a bunch
of bright dots in a
pentagonal kind of symmetry.
It looks very funny.
If you go to this Caltech
website, you will see it.
And then people also noticed
that this kind of thing
also produces Talbot patterns.
If you you diffract a field
from a pentagonal quasi-crystal,
it will produce Talbot patterns
as you'll go behind it.
And that caused
quite a bit of stir.
Actually there's a lot of papers
analyzing this and looking
into this interest.
Anyway, so I don't know
if this has any use--
it's kind of
interesting physics.
But yeah, people spend
some time on that.
Oh, yeah.
Actually, Talbot effect
found a use recently
in a very surprising
way in lithography.
It is a very easy way to
reproduce a pattern lenslessly,
as long as the
pattern is periodic.
And so for planar
lithography is not
that interesting,
but nowadays many
people who want to make photonic
crystals which are periodic.
So in the photonic crystals, you
want to start with the volume.
So this is a
cross-section, and you
want to write patterns
that look like this.
So for example, what you
do is you take a polymer--
OK, I take it back.
You take a monomer and if you
could expose some [INAUDIBLE]
these regions and
then you develop it,
then you would end up
with a structure that
has low index in the unexposed
regions and high index
in exposed regions.
That is a photonic crystal.
So the question is
how could you do this.
Well, one way is
with a Talbot effect
because a Talbot effect will
actually focus the light very
sharply in the Talbot planes and
then you'll get your exposure.
But everywhere else, the
light is kind of diffuse.
So it does not expose very much.
So if you play with the
threshold of the photoresist,
you can actually get the
pattern to work like this.
So there's a colleague of
mine at MIT, Ned Thomas.
I don't know if any of Ned's
students are in the class.
But he came up with
a very clever system
that he can expose and create
photonic crystals this way.
And then interestingly,
a student of mine
discovered that if you vary
the duty cycle of this thing,
I may be disclosing--
everybody here is MIT, right?
And those of you who are
NUS are sort of bound
by a vow of secrecy or whatever.
But anyway, I may be
disclosing something
that we have a
patent pending for.
But anyway, so it
is also well known--
people have analyzed
patterns with a duty cycle
that these different
[INAUDIBLE] point have.
So for example, if you have a
gradient that is like this--
this also produces
a Talbot effect.
So it will also produce
replicas of that pattern.
So but my student discovered
that if you vary the duty
cycle, that's really
interesting and we don't fully
understand why but it is true.
I mean, it is physically
correct-- we don't know how
to explain it very intuitively.
But mathematically,
you find that you have
a pattern with a fixed period.
But the variable duty cycle,
for example, like this,
it also for this
is a Talbot effect.
Not forever, but over a
finite region maybe about--
I don't know, it depends but
maybe about 10 or so Talbot
planes, it reproduces itself.
So it is also possible to
make non-periodic patterns,
which as [? Colin ?] knows,
we're very interested in making
non-periodic kind of--
they're not for [? tiny ?]
crystals anymore,
but they're not periodic
strong index modulations.
That is possibly
one way to do it.
AUDIENCE: George,
it seems like it
seems like that was still
a periodic pattern though.
TA: No, because the
duty cycle varies.
We call it periodic because
you must have the same duty
cycle in every period.
AUDIENCE: So even though
it repeats every period
with a different duty
cycle, that's not periodic.
TA: I don't know, would you
call this function periodic?
AUDIENCE: I understand what
you mean about the duty
cycle changing, but it's
got a definite period to it
where features are--
TA: Yeah.
Yeah, but it's non-periodic.
OK, what you're saying
is a possible explanation
for why it has a Talbot effect.
It has a Talbot
effect because it
has this fundamental period
underlined the variable duty
cycle.
AUDIENCE: Right, I
look at the duty cycle
as changing the orders
that are coming out
for that particular region.
TA: Well, in a slowly varying
approximation, perhaps.
Yes.
I mean, this thing--
I've not looking at
the diffraction pattern
of this thing in detail.
But yes, it would produce
diffracted orders.
But it is not clear how you
would compute their strength
from a Fourier series.
At least, I don't
know how to do it.
There may be a way with somebody
adiabatic approximation.
Because it is true
that in our simulation,
the duty cycle was
very slowly varied.
And I believe it is also true.
In fact, I think Will--
my student who did this--
he also did this simulation
with a fast, varying duty
cycle, and he found out
that the Talbot effect
actually does not happen
if the duty cycle varies fast.
So, yeah.
There's certainly an adiabatic
approximation happening here.
But I guess we haven't really
worked out all the details.
But it is sort of
interesting still.
Anyway, yeah, it's one
of those things that--
the reason I'm bringing it up
is because the Talbot effect
doesn't look like something
particularly useful.
It looks more like a curiosity.
But yeah, I guess
sometimes even curiosities
can find applications, right?